강의 좀 앞부분에서 이 채널에 대해 관찰한 것에 기반해서요. 그리고 다시 한번 필요한 조건은 확인하기 꽤 간단해요.
도움이 된다면 연습 문제로 풀어보세요. 완전 편극 제거 채널을 고려해 봐요.
모든 밀도 행렬 입력에 대해 완전 혼합 상태를 출력하는 채널이에요. 이 채널에는 네 개의 Kraus 행렬이
필요해요. n이 3 이하인 Kraus 표현을 만드는 건 불가능해요. 작동하는 한 가지 선택이 여기 있고,
또 다른 선택도 있어요. 연습 문제는 이 선택들이 작동하는지 확인하고 필요한 조건이
충족되는지 확인하는 거예요. 두 번째 대안은 기본적으로 qubit을 완전히 편극 제거하거나, 다시 말해
항등을 포함한 네 개의 Pauli 행렬 중 하나를 무작위로 선택하고
해당 unitary 연산을 qubit에 적용해서 완전히 랜덤화하는 것이 가능하다는 걸 보여줘요. 그래서 완전 편극 제거 채널은 혼합
unitary 채널의 또 다른 예시예요. 다룰 세 가지 채널 표현 중 마지막은 Choi 표현이에요. Man-Duen Choi는
행렬 이론과 다른 주제들을 연구하는 수학자이고, Choi 표현은 그의 이름을 딴 거예요.
어떤 의미에서 이 모든 것을 하나로 묶는 1975년에 발표한 정말 우아한 논문에 기반해서요. 채널 Φ의 Choi
표현은 관례적으로 J_Φ로 표시되는 단일 행렬이에요. 구체적으로 입력 시스템에 n개의 고전적 상태가 있고
출력 시스템에 m개의 고전적 상태가 있으면, Φ의 Choi 표현은
n*m × n*m 정방 행렬이 돼요. 정확히 행렬이 어떻게 정의되는지 말씀드리기 전에, 핵심 특성 몇 가지를 언급하고 싶어요.
이건 적어도 표면적으로는 실제 정의 자체가 하지 않는 방식으로 표현에 동기를 부여해요. 첫째로, Stinespring 표현과 Kraus 표현 모두와 달리, Choi 표현은
소위 충실한 표현으로, 모든 채널이 정확히 하나를 갖는다는 의미예요. 이건 꽤 중요해요.
두 채널이 같다는 것은 그것들의 Choi 표현이 같은 경우에만 성립하기 때문이에요. 그래서 두 채널에 대해
두 가지 다른 Stinespring 표현이나 두 가지 다른 Kraus 표현 또는 각각 하나씩 같은 두 가지 다른 설명이 있고
그것들이 실제로 같은 채널인지 알고 싶다면, Choi 표현을 계산해서
같은지 확인하면 돼요. 두 번째 특성은 Choi 표현에 유효한 채널인 경우에만 성립하는
간단한 확인 조건들이 있다는 거예요. 그 특성이 그렇게 특별하진 않아요. 다른 두 표현에 대해서도 같은 말을 할 수 있지만,
그래도 갖는 게 좋은 특성이고, 곧 더 자세히 논의할 거예요. Choi 표현에 대해 주목할 또 한 가지는, 비록 채널을
행렬로 표현하고 있지만, 이 행렬이 직접 채널을 선형 사상으로 나타내지는 않는다는 거예요. 실제로
Choi 표현을 선형 사상을 설명하는 것으로 생각하기보다는 특정 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬과 연결하는 게 더 자연스러워요.
하지만 꽤 간단한 공식을 사용해서 Choi 표현으로부터 채널의 작용을 복원하는 건 가능해요.
하지만 그게 단순한 행렬 곱셈만큼 간단하진 않아요.
서론은 이 정도면 충분하고, 실제 정의로 넘어가봐요. Φ가 시스템 X에서 시스템 Y로의 채널이라고 가정하고
입력 시스템 X의 고전적 상태 집합이 Σ라고 가정해요. 출력 시스템의 고전적 상태 집합은 언급할 필요가 없어서
정의에서 이름을 붙일 필요가 없어요. Φ의 Choi 표현은 화면에 표시된 식으로 정의돼요.
입력 시스템의 모든 고전적 상태 A와 B에 걸친 합이 있고,
|a⟩⟨b|와 채널 Φ를 |a⟩⟨b|에 적용한 것의 텐서곱을 합산해요.
이 표현은 공식에 의해 정의되고, 이 공식을 생각하는 몇 가지 다른 방법이 있어요. 하지만 논의하기 전에,
Choi 표현이 때로 두 텐서 인수의 순서가 반대인 약간 다른 방식으로 정의된다는 걸 말씀드릴게요.
즉 Φ(|a⟩⟨b|)가 두 번째 텐서 인수가 아닌 첫 번째 텐서 인수로 나타나요. 하지만 이 두 방식은
이 간단한 대칭성까지는 동등해요. 즉, 이 표현을 사용할 때는
어떤 순서를 사용하는지 명확히 하는 게 좋아요. 이 순서는 Qiskit에서 쓰는 방식이고, 블록 행렬 관점에서
표현을 시각적으로 설명하기도 더 좋아요. 그래서 이걸 사용할 거예요. 블록 행렬
설명을 더 정확히 하면, 고전적 상태 집합 Σ가 어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수로 구성된다고 가정하면
J_Φ를 화면에서 보이는 것처럼 블록 행렬로 대안적으로 쓸 수 있어요.
다시 말해, Φ의 Choi 표현은 정확히 하나의 항목이 1이고 나머지 항목이 모두 0인 각 입력 행렬에
Φ를 적용해서 얻는 행렬이에요. 그리고 그것들을 꽤 자연스러운 방식으로
배열해요. 왜 이런 행렬을 형성하고 싶은지 선험적으로 명확하지 않을 수 있지만,
매우 유용한 것으로 밝혀져요. 주목할 한 가지는, A와 B 모두 0부터 n-1까지의 정수를 범위로 할 때
|a⟩⟨b| 행렬들을 포함하는 집합이 모든 n×n 행렬의 공간에 대한 기저를 형성한다는 거예요. 그래서
이 행렬이 있으면, 선형성에 의해 Φ가 임의의 n×n 행렬에 무엇을 하는지 분명히 결정할 수 있어요.
구체적으로는 블록들의 적절한 선형 결합을 취해서요. 그래서 행렬 J_Φ는 실제로 Φ를 선형 사상으로 유일하게
결정해요. 채널의 Choi 표현을 생각하는 또 다른 방법은, 이게
정규화했을 때, 즉 소문자 n으로 표시할 입력 시스템의 고전적 상태 수로 나눴을 때
상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현한다는 거예요. 이렇게 하면 항상 밀도 행렬을 얻는데,
이를 채널의 Choi 상태라고 해요. 더 자세히 살펴보면,
먼저 입력 시스템의 두 개의 동일한 복사본이 있고, 화면에 표시된 양자 상태 벡터 ψ를 고려한다고 상상해 봐요.
이건 이 동일한 시스템 쌍의 소위 최대 얽힘 상태를 나타내요.
예를 들어 Σ가 이진 알파벳이면, 이건 Φ+ 상태예요. 하지만 임의의 Σ 선택에 대해 유사하게 정의된 상태를 생각할 수 있고,
그 결과는 고도로 얽힌 상태인데, 실제로 이 시스템 선택으로 얻을 수 있는 만큼 얽혀 있어요.
상태의 밀도 행렬 표현을 얻기 위해 상태 벡터와 켤레 전치를 곱하고, 이런 모습이에요.
마지막으로 n으로 나눈 채널의 Choi 표현을 생각해 보면, 채널 Φ를 두 번째 시스템에 적용하면 얻을 상태임을 알 수 있어요.
그림 형태로 보면, 이게 어떻게 보이는지예요. 최대 얽힘 상태 ψ에 있는 두 개의 시스템 X 복사본이 있어요. 채널 Φ는
다이어그램에서 위쪽인 두 번째 시스템에 적용되고, 결과 상태가 Φ의 Choi 상태예요. 물론 일반적으로는
두 개의 다른 시스템에 같은 이름을 붙이지 않아요. 일반적으로 두 개의 다른 것에 같은 이름을 붙이는 건 도움이 되지 않지만,
여기서는 말이 돼요.
어쨌든 이건 꽤 자연스러운 구성이에요.